The world’s fastest hunter
the peregrine falcon
snatches prey out of the sky at speeds of >300 km/hr.
This breakneck speed gives
these predators the element of surprise.
It also lets them outmaneuver their prey,
As you can see from this drone footage,
it’s hard to study falcon attack dives
or “stoops” in real time.
Because they happen so fast.
So researchers turned to 3D simulations
of a computer-generated peregrine falcon
trying to catch a computer-generated starling.
The team found that the falcon was best off diving
at roughly 150 km/hr.
when the starling flew in a straight path.
But if the starling was flying erratically
the falcon stood the greatest chance of success
by stooping at much higher speeds
around 360 km/hr.
You’d think that the higher speeds would make it harder
for falcons to adjust to a moving target.
But the opposite turned out to be true.
Because they could generate more turning force
the predators were more maneuverable
at higher speeds.
And it was only at these top speeds
that the falcons able to outmaneuver the agile starlings.
So stoops don’t just help falcons overtake prey
they also help the predators change direction.